[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
У нас пісок, піщана земля...
[Поділля,
Вільшанка]
... І в нас дуже погано родить кукурудза, картопля.
Це через пісок.
[Софія Гудзь
Віникарка]
А в сусідніх селах черноземи,
там і кукурудза, і картопля родить.
А в нас лише просо.
Воно не боїться спеки і піску.
Оце насіння.
[Василь Гудзь
Віникар]
Це нечищене насіння.
Щоб сіяти, ми обираємо найкраще.
Воно чисте, зернисте.
І ось так воно сходить,
— ...а потім з цього виростає ось таке.
— Це насіння таке дрібне.
З насіння виростає...
З однієї такої зернинки виростає ось таке просо.
Посіяти треба, потім сапати.
Тоді воно виростає ось таке.
Зрізаємо, чистимо, складаємо у в'язки.
Потім обв'язуємо мотузкою.
Складаємо три пучки і робимо віник.
— Ти обмотала?
— Так.
[Тетяна Гудзь
Віникарка]
— А де мій ножик?
— Там.
А ні, є.
Зараз із заготовок робитимемо віник.
Це все ручна робота.
Казали, що роботи є. Та які роботи?
Треба лише руки й ноги.
Я не сиджу багато.
25 штук за день в мене норма.
25 віників зв'язав — і все.
То я в'яжу за 2,5-3 години 25 штук.
Колись їх в'язали лозою,
але тепер з лозою не беруть,
беруть з мотузкою.
Тож в'яжемо мотузкою.
Зараз, коли сухо, вона лопається.
Як перший віник — ніяк не вдається.
У восьмому класі я тоді був.
Щоправда, він у мене вийшов поганий.
Так старався по одному, по два, по три в'язати.
У нас люди є, що й по сотні в день в'яжуть.
Але на базарі кажуть,
що вільшанецькі віники найкращі.
Не всі, але є.
[Поділля,
Саврань]
У нас в Саврані зробили віничний базар.
Два рази на тиждень працює цей гуртовий базар.
Сюди приїжджають гуртовики з всієї України.
Ми привозимо сюди віники.
Пачками по 50 штук стюковуємо.
Базар є у вівторок і четвер.
Я на базар не вожу,
а в'яжу віники на замовлення.
У мене свої є клієнти,
то я їм нав'язав.
Вони дзвонять, питають:
«Скільки є? Сотня, дві, три?»
Зі стрічкою — то подарункові.
А так я на базар не завожу.
...І от зараз лишилася ручка.
Зараз ми подарунковий робимо.
Саму ручку
ось так обмотуємо.
Тобто ручку стрічкою обплетемо,
щоб він був більш ошатний і впадав в очі.
Ось такий получається віник.
Ось це ми зрізаємо.
Маємо такий віник.
Без стрічок поки.
Зараз ще його прикрасимо.
Традиція ця існує давно.
Я не пам'ятаю навіть, багато років минуло.
Деякі приїжджають, кажуть, що їм би пилосос,
віник — то дорого,
а інші кажуть: «Та ні»...
Йому не потрібна електроенергія.
Тільки треба ним вміти користуватися.
Пилосос — то не то.
Екологічнішого за віник нічого нема.
Хімія з віником не пов'язана.
Екологічний пилосос.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Портян]
[Продюсерка
Ольга Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Музика
Sasha Boole]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]